he's about to enter or he's right in the
middle of right now i guess
his 12th season as being the head coach
of the seattle seahawks
he is pete carroll back here on the rich
eisen show how are you coach
i'm good rich what's up brother i'm
better for talking to you
uh what does a mid-may 2021 look like
for you just finished up with the rookie
mini camp right that's basically where
you are and everything yeah
yeah it's a little bit different it's
different than last year and last year
was different than the year before so
uh we're just we just work our way
through uh as things are you know have
have changed some and uh uh but things
are going well uh
we made the we think we maxed out what
that which we could in the draft we like
our guys and and excited about the
the young pups that we're working with
um you know we're deep deep into zoom
right now
we're in zoom land and uh our coaches
and our players are exceedingly
uh adept at it now and getting a lot out
of it again as we did last year
um so it's it's a new day it's it's
really it's a new day
so what do you expect uh of of seeing
players physically in front of you um
what is your level of expectation over
the next several weeks on that front
pete well we'll see more we'll see more
than we have now we got 30 something
guys here now
uh working and and uh we'll see more
guys as we as we move along we'll
work towards our uh our mini camp coming
up
in the middle of june and that would be
the the culmination of it so
i'm hoping that we'll increase our
numbers as we go and i know our guys are
working really hard everybody's really
dedicated to that and and they're
getting together where they can and when
they can and so
there's a lot of good positive stuff
happening what do you make sen what do
you make of the
the conversation on that front uh in
recent days that
last year because of the pandemic and so
much of
uh off-season work was done by zoom and
the regular season
looked like any other season that maybe
the in-person work year-round is
something that
uh is not necessary that it's too much
and that things should be um kind of the
way they are
right now what are you as a head coach
in the nfl now in a 12th year on that
front
uh would just seattle say about that
well i i i i think
it's worthwhile discussion because it
because it's it's on the top of
of everybody's mind and in particular
the players in in
they're trying to figure out what's best
what we know is when it's equal
it comes out fine and last year nobody
had off season we had no preseason games
and the season really measured up to be
uh you know
comparable season ones in the past this
is happening a little different this
time around
and it's not within the control of of of
anybody to keep everybody
on the same numbers and days and work
and work
load and all of that so this is going to
be a little bit different and we need to
see how that that pans out
but uh when it's when it's uh controlled
and and it's equal for all all members
then it it'll work out fine and so
i think our players learned that and our
coaches saw that last year too you know
it wasn't
we didn't think it was the ideal but yet
as long as it's relative and the comp
and the competitive
uh landscape is the same then it then it
works out fine pete carroll here on the
rich eisen show
um so let's get into uh
russ and um his conversation that he's
been having publicly in a manner that we
haven't really heard from him
about his level of protection and and
needing that upgraded and and his desire
to still be
with you and in seattle how would your
you rate your relationship with russell
wilson is you and i are talking right
here in the middle of may
pete cowell yeah well it seems like it's
really old news to talk about this
because it's been such a long time which
he the little bit that he said
carried so much air time that uh it it
it became bigger than life uh though
throughout the whole process russell
we've always been connected we've always
been talking we've never
not been in in communication and we
weren't at all at this this time either
and uh a couple of things that came out
got magnified
and the questions came out and there was
a couple things you know he was
frustrated when he was talking
just like any of us can sometimes
emphasize something that's
you know on the top of our mind and it
can it can be
played differently than it really played
itself out
we've had a really good offseason of
working and uh
and there was an ongoing media
discussion that i did not take part in
john and i did not we refused it to be
party to that
and russ did what he could once once he
saw it happening
to stay as quiet as he could because we
it was going to play
and have a life of its own anyway so
what what it amounted to
was uh i think a refocusing you know
making sure that we were on the same
page making sure that we were clear
so that we could withstand any of the
scrutiny that would come come towards us
and we did that and so uh
we've had a good offseason and we're
we're cranking he's fired up and and
about his team he's fired up about his
coaching staff
he's fired up about the season coming up
and and he just as he knows how to do
he's been competing
his his butt off to be right and ready
and
and be on point so um it's gone very
well uh
even though that discussion lasted so
long and you had certain guys
that just decided to keep the story
going and they just wanted to keep
feeding it
and uh that's that it really was much
bigger than that it was
for us internally and i thought we
handled it really well well the reason
why i bring it up i guess with you now
is you and i have not had not spoken
since then and that that was such a
conversation
no no no i'm just no no but i understand
what's just like okay i thought you did
that you know that that page had been
turned
but the the the book is still open in
terms of a national conversation
with with just quarterbacks it shouldn't
it shouldn't be
well it shouldn't be you know in terms
of up here in seattle it shouldn't be
but i i get it that the guys are doing
it and i know aaron's
been real vocal and whatever is going on
there it keeps this discussion alive and
and uh and so you know it's it's fun for
the media and they do what they got to
do with it and it's okay
well you do bring up where i guess i was
going next with
with aaron in wisconsin in the concept
of you know hey a quarterback should
have a say in
and who's on the roster and certainly
about the way an offense is running
how much is russell involved in all of
that with you
and the rest of the staff now there's a
new offensive coordinator and shane
waldron being brought in right now how
how much is
is that uh if you're willing to pull
back the curtain on uh that he is
involved in that
conversation pete carroll yeah well rich
first let me say
in a real general sense either competing
or not and
with that means that if if there's
information that you can have and you
can you have access to and it can help
you make choices and decisions that you
make
i've always been talking to players
there's been guys over the years i've
had in my office recall them on the
phone or now we do our text in
you know that there's something that
comes up they've got information they've
got
special knowledge i've always i've never
hesitated to do that
russ haven't been here for 10 years now
he's been around us a long time and he's
got a good perspective as does bobby
wagner
and uh we're fortunate to have dwayne
brown and guys they have opinions
that i don't have to act on the
information but i want to access the
information i'm okay with that you know
so i've always been talking to guys
so how much does he have now not he
doesn't have any more than
than than he's ever had uh i be i've
respected the heck out of us
for all of the reasons that he has
proven he's worthy
and so when i can i get a chance to get
something from they can help me out i'm
going to them i don't hesitate to do
that and i'll do it with any of our guys
doug baldwin was the guy richard sherman
was guys i would talk to those guys
about
scheme personnel situations times those
social issues i mean you name it you
know and that's that's the kind of
program that we have run around here so
um i don't think it should be over over
played
and i don't think it should be a
misstated either
uh russ has a lot of good information so
i'm i go to when i think it's
appropriate
and he'll bring ideas at times to me
just to try them out
we have that kind of relationship where
it's okay to do that but i'm not closing
it off to anybody
and i i i can't tell you how much i
talked to bobby whitener because he's
been around here ten years too
you know and those guys have something
to they have great
insights and so that's just competing to
me you know it's no different so
pete carroll here on the rich eisen show
uh shane waldron comes from
uh here in los angeles uh from the rams
is that the similar offense are we going
to see something similar where
where uh you'll see a bunch of similar
sets but uh you have no earthly idea
what play is going to be run from it is
that is that what's being brought
to let russ cook if you will to seattle
right now
well well we've been through i don't
know about the cook part of it okay
that's somebody else's deal
that's that's not mine but uh the um
we've run a lot of offense here over the
years we've done a lot of stuff we've
we've been a productive team for a lot
of years and
russell has been a highly productive
quarterback and efficient
explosive he's been able to run uh with
the ball that he had almost 500 yards
again last year you know and
there's there's a lot of stuff here that
we have and that's
shane's shane's challenge is to put all
that together
with this marvelous background that that
the guys have coming out of their their
history and their system
you know i go all the way back richard
you look all the way back to
this goes back to mike shanahan and alex
gibbs you know
where this offensive concept started
when i was in
nsc in year two i had alex gibbs come in
and help me
install a run game and and the play
passes off to that i mean that's a long
that's 20 something
years ago which was all because of the
respect that i had from mike shanahan
in the background of what they had put
together coming out of the bill walsh
uh west coast system and and i think
really
the kind of the godfather of this thing
is uh is bill walsh but yet
the the relationships that have been
powerful with mike shanahan
and so he what i'm saying is they have
influenced kyle they've been influenced
sean down in l.a so many guys all over
the league now
uh with the real discipline about their
style of
coaching and uh that applies to a lot of
different scheme
so that's what we're really excited
about shane bringing in is
is the mentality of how to make things
really sharp and really precise
and really clean and and varied as well
uh and then
adapt it to our people and and our qb
and and all of that
and we're having a blast i'm having so
much fun because i'm i feel like i'm
more
connected to the heart of where it all
comes from
and and shane doesn't even know i mean
he's such a young guy i mean he
he knows who mike shanahan is but he has
never really you know
have the direct influence as much as a
lot of guys but it's really exciting for
me and i love
i love tapping into it because i've been
a student of it for a long time
you certainly have pete carroll and um
you know age is just a number
you know where i'm going with this too
um you're you're hitting the big
7-0 um what are you thinking of retiring
are you thinking
no no no no because it blows me away i
remember when
when you were the head coach of the jets
and the patriots and people were
wondering if you were the right coach
because you're playing basketball with
the guys you know what i mean like and
and clearly you know really i mean you
remember all that stuff i'm sure
and and you've been at this for
absolutely quite a long time
so i guess my question for you is is how
much longer do you
do you want to do it you sound like
you're having a blast but how much
like wha what it's still a very
demanding job
so how how how long do you want to keep
doing this
what are you saying rich it's no more
demanding today than it was you know the
last 10 years of it so
um i you know i find that i find the job
really fun i like you said
and and i enjoyed the challenge of it
and uh i'm excited about it every day
i'm fired up about these about the young
guys and the old guys and the coaches
and the whole
there's nothing that the competition of
it there's nothing that i'm not fired up
about
and so why would you know why would i
set numbers on it
i i i've said this before that uh david
brooks wrote
wrote one time about uh he declared
how to deal with this question of when
you know when are you going to wind up
your career
with taking a five-year approach to it
and you look at five years and
in five years some will ask that
question and figure it out
well that's i got five more years every
year you know so you know
i'm not i'm not concerned about it at
all i'm just having fun doing it and i
want to do it really well
and want to win as much as we possibly
can and so that consumes everything that
we have and
and i don't feel like there's a with
there's a
gauge on the tank right now you know
like how much how much i got left in
there so i'm just pretty pumped up about
it staying in good shape and
working hard in my family supporting it
and so uh we're having a blast
we gotta win that no i know you gotta
win no i hear you in that
if we keep doing that then and plus
you've got a tremendous
you know roster of of players i mean
one one of them being and this will help
keep you you know engaged as well no
doubt about it
not not as if you you need that at all
but dk metcalf
running a 100 meter was something that
caught so many people's attention and
he's so dynamic he is so unique
he is so built i mean my god
it is it is something else what
next step do you think he can take
because you're one
year you know zero to year one was
something else last year was
breathtaking
what do you think this can look like for
dk
in your uh your new offensive line this
year the the one
one of the descriptive words you said
was dynamic you know
that that to me i i hear that word i
don't
there's nothing physical about that
other than what influences the the
thought of
you know what he represents as a as a
total person this is an extraordinary
young man
he he's he's a fascinating guy and and
it's not
you know everybody gets attracted to the
physical stuff well that just happens to
be but
he's recognized rich that that he's got
an opportunity to do something really
special
and he's not going to miss it and he's
going to go as far as he's got to go
push as hard as he's got to push uh
spend as much clarity
of thinking and mind time and mentality
uh mindfulness uh towards it so that he
can he can max it out
to a point where you know i worry about
to he puts too much on himself
in that regard because he's a marvelous
player and uh and he's a really bright
football player too and in competitors
as you just saw look at look at how he
was able to apply his skills
in his background uh in such a limited
background in track
and look like that you know and just be
competitive and just in the
in the race you know give him a couple
more finishes uh
under his belt he might have been a
little bit looser a little bit smoother
he might have been right in the front of
that thing he wasn't far enough behind
it
he would do anything but to scare you
you know that he could have
um what's next you know i i you know
i just happened to be texting with him
just a night ago and
he was talking about some people that
are that he's talking with that
that are starting to talk about some
other things and some other choices
he he's he's got a big enough mind and a
big enough awareness that that he's able
to
encompass a lot of stuff and i'm gonna
i'm gonna boost him up and
pump him to to wherever he wants to go
and and and follow
really his lead on you know where this
career takes him
but it's going to be more than football
he's going to have a lot more to offer
the the world
uh as he goes on and i just i hope he
can stay in good health and just and
just keep enjoying the fruits of it and
and uh
and just follow along he's got it it's
going to be a terrific story to follow
you certainly piqued my interest he had
me at hello too when
at the combine when he's crying talking
to his mom
after he worked out you know with the
decisions that he made
you know with his neck and the injuries
and and and
you know i'm all i'm all about distance
traveled in journeys i mean his
is fascinating to me and then you know
he runs down buddha baker for crying out
loud i mean my god
he he really is somebody who i can't
wait to see
in the next year and before i let you go
uh pete carroll
you mentioned bobby wagner a few times i
think he's gonna have a gold jacket one
day
um is it possible i read
uh you if you tell me it's true or not i
think you were quoted as saying is it
true richard sherman you've been
chatting with him it's possible to maybe
get uh
a legion of boomer back in the mix is
that possible
for you well if i if i respond
uh in such a manner here that would be
the only thing that comes out of this
interview right now
that we had but i've richard and i have
been in contact over the years and we
continue to be in
and i know he's working hard and looking
for an opportunity and he's got a lot of
things going
uh in his world too that are really
exciting as well
and you know you never know we're always
competing in in and working at stuff and
and sherm knows that and and i i really
at this point i don't have the
that in our plans okay but yet it's not
it's never out of my mind you know and
uh
you know i love our guys for all of the
time we spent together and all that we
went through together the ups the downs
the challenges
it was just life you know that we've
we've lived and we've shared a life
in this world of football and and i'm
really grateful for the relationships of
those guys that have played in the past
and
i love them and and uh you know i'll be
there for them at any time that they
need me and as best i can and
uh because they've given me everything
that they ever could too you know so
it's a great relationship i'm i'm fond
of all those guys and and
you know if ever there's a chance i can
let me look at what happened with
marshawn a couple years back man that
was freaking
awesome you know i came back and almost
scored the winning touchdown in the
you know come on he scored three times
in the last couple games you know or
whatever it was four times
um that was such a marvelous story we
were inches away from that being the
storybook and
and uh and who knows you know you never
know what's gonna happen you know i
haven't heard from marshawn in a while
but you know
that could be just as much of a story as
any of them so i doubt um i love our
guys and
hope they're doing well and and we'll
look after them forever well pete i
appreciate the time
there's one last question i've never
asked you i wanted to ask you so i'm
gonna do it
how many pieces of gum do you go through
during the game how many pieces of gum
do you go through during
a four or five four percent it's not the
first time that question has been asked
but i never really count but give me an
estimate what do you got but since
since the masks came in masks really
took something away from it now because
that thing chomping up and down just
don't get it you know and so sure but
yes but yeah it is i'm at least before
packer okay i'm gonna leave the four
packers
now what are you chewing though what's
your choice what do you got
what do you do i'm a bubble yum i've
been a bubble yum guy for a long time
all the way
all the way uh back to uh uh my boy back
you know uh dominguez back at sc man
we've been double y um in the whole uh
bubble yup the whole time okay right
just bubble gum flavor
mint what do you got for me pete it just
it doesn't matter just yeah yeah just
bubble gum
yeah straight pink straight straight
pink straight pink four packers
four uh love it four
nothing like when you get one it's not
it's not just one is when you get two
and three you get to that fourth one in
in
your in your chart at the time right now
you're really living them
pete you thank you so much no no there's
no editing
come on now whatever you want no this is
great this is now this is gonna be
that's going to be the headline out of
all of it before we discuss pete
it'll be the bubble gum thanks for the
time
you are you got it you bet that's the
one and only pete carroll head coach of
the seattle seahawks right here on the
rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here